no doubt the two seymour was very good
yeah and a change up too but yeah that
you know that's aaron's bread and butter
and how many times he told us that this
is his weather
hot and muggy
no balls of two strikes
throws another curve ball cut out and
missed what out here in the first inning
yeah when you have to guard against
three pitches
especially as good as
aaron's off speed is it it's not an easy
day swing gonna miss he threw him a
change up down and in
two strikeouts in a row let's do it too
aaron trying to continue what has been a
good run for the philly's starting
pitchers
done what they're supposed to called
strike three three k's in the inning
for aranola no runs one hit
and a man left that's a good start for
aranola we'll go to the bottom of the
first philly's coming up for the first
time to face right here jordan holloway
a 25 year old
a former 20th round pick by the marlins
back in 2014. here's the 1-2 pitch
fastball check swing oh phil cuz he says
he went around
herrera kind of standing at the plate
looking back at the home plate umpire
oh two to segura
and shigura down on strikes breaking
ball from holloway he's got two k's
2-2 from holloway blows him away with a
fastball and holloway strikes out the
side in the first
not bad at all
and now joe bennett's first at-bat as a
miami marlin
joe panic fly ball right field goodbye
or should i say hello
welcome to the marlins joe panic a solo
home run hell indeed it's a hello how
are you doing joe panic welcome to the
marlins the offense much appreciated
early offense for the marlins and what
did it bat after a couple of called
strikes
worked his way back into the count bryce
harper leads it off
[Music]
that balls hit well deep to center field
going back is marty it is gone
off the wall in center field that was a
shock
and bryce harper has just tied this ball
game up at one here in the bottom of the
second inning
that's gonna leave a mark out in center
fields
i'll tell you what i i don't know how
hard to exit velocity i'm sure we're
going to find out but my goodness that's
a line drive to hit off the batter's eye
up there above the ivy six hits all
singles but they were winning by how
much that's a fair ball going down the
right field line misplayed by duvall
two runs are gonna score mccutcheon
crosses the plate bowm is across the
plate sliding into third with a two-run
triple
is nick maton
it's his first major league triple and
the phillies lead it 3-1 1-2
[Applause]
he went around in a curveball
six strikeouts
for aaron
2-2
and a strike three called on the inside
corner
it's been a strike a lot already tonight
one and two
martay doesn't go and a called strike
three on the outside corner eight
strikeouts for aaron nola through three
innings
[Applause]
no runs one hit
a lot of sweat they've all struck out
looking his first time up
duvall
fly ball left field this one's going to
go into the second deck
adam duvall with a home run off of
aranola
think he's on another one of those hot
streaks
well he's starting to heat up a long
home run to center field last night on
101 mile an hour fastball this in 84
mile an hour change up
sanchez takes off
and a breaking ball strike three call
number 10 for aaron nola it's only the
fourth inning and he's got 10 strikeouts
the 20th career double-digit strikeout
game and number 16 at citizens bag park
brings segura up with a chance to add to
the phil's lead count us two and two
and a line drive off the bound into
center field one run is in the hold nola
third rbi for segura the phillies add-on
it's a 5-2 ball game and miguel rojas at
the plate
they've got themselves a few hits into
center field falling fast for a base hit
cooper around third he's going to score
and another two strike two out hit for
the marlins
three in a row and they are within a run
now it's just a one run game and the
tying run
is 90 feet away with two outs and it's
jesus sanchez
oh and that's a base it into right field
sanchez ties the game miggy on his way
to third how do you like that aaron nola
dominated
through the first
four innings tonight
and the marlins fight back with four
straight two out singles it's 5-5
and joe girardi is heading out that's it
for aranola
we've got a pitching change here in the
fifth inning
11 strikeouts for aaron nola but he's
allowed five runs
well two strikes
where the marlins have done their damage
this inning
find a way to come up with a big hit
like that base it up the middle that'll
score miggy
on his way to third is sanchez and
another
two strike two out rbi single 6'5
marlins now sandy leone
he didn't even wait for two strikes well
it's not going to be a single either
sandy leone into the right field corner
one run will score
here comes panic around third
he's in there
and sandy leone drives home two more
marlins taking eight to five lead
harper's got a couple hits tonight he's
homered
lined out and single
that is crushed i mean absolutely
crushed
second deck home run it's his second
home run of the night
he has 13 solo home runs this year
and it's now a 10-6 ball game
[Applause]
swinging a miss the ball game is over
the phillies
had a three-run lead two different times
in tonight's ball game and they lose it
by a final score of 11-6